welcome this is gonna be super fun for
me because we actually don't really know
each other we just met backstage I don't
know how we got here these two chairs
yeah this situation but happy about who
we are I'm very happy just gonna be fun
I have some questions that I thought up
the first the biggest question of course
I've been wanting to ask how did you
write sexy back
did it just that's a good question sorry
that's not what I saw that okay no I'm
comfortable answering anything you know
what seriously
your agents and managers said they'd
rather know you don't have your own sex
they don't want me giving away my
secrets but how did we you started when
you were 16 in computers I started 16
doing stand-up comedy mm-hmm and yet
we're in we're now on stage somewhere
talking to each other and just it's
funny isn't it weird how that happens
it's kind of fun
strange but I mean how did that did you
you because I've read those annoying
things about you and like I don't want
to dwell on the past of course but that
scares me that you've read a zillion
things about me it well that's the way
well thanks to Facebook you can read a
lot of things about a lot of people but
you uh you start your hacker right would
you yeah uncomfortable by saying I
wouldn't I wouldn't characterize it that
way no I would you know I would I was a
member of an elite elite underground
group of cyber criminals
now what what was some of his people
want me to this day yeah yeah I had a
weird friend in high school that would
do weird like he what this is I mean
you're younger than me but we were young
prodigy AOL where were you mm-hmm
they were jokes now so if you're if
you're if you're if you were a member of
the computer underground you sort of
there was like a hierarchy I was on the
bottom of that hierarchy I was like the
guy who was on like the conference calls
going please give me an exploit come on
tell me how it works please what to tell
me and and and so yeah but I would never
be caught dead on AOL that would have
been like that would have been social
suicide in my elite amongst my elite
cyber criminal acts cream with the
blinking cursor and that's you love that
type of stuff yes you don't want a
swooshing triangle what's fun I wanted I
wanted I wanted the thrill of breaking
into a machine and getting that pound
sign to appear that route you know it
was looking up modems and phone lines
and why cuz I ran a BBS yeah yeah I ran
it I ran a BBS a bulletin board system
yeah that's what they don't support yeah
people could die they just scare me
these little bit of a girl you know what
mine was called no realm of darkness of
course it was of course it was hmm
and what if you talk about did you talk
about like King's Quest the sheets on
there what did you talk about like video
game I mean it was all Dungeons &
Dragons Satanism ya know the usual the
usual yeah Satanism oh is a good way to
wake up in the morning I had another
bulletin board after that one this one
and this the much more successful
actually I decided that that if you were
calling from the United States you
really should not be allowed to call my
bulletin board because all the elite
hackers were in you know these you know
like former Soviet bloc countries whose
names I can't pronounce but that's where
the elite hackers come from so I said I
want those guys so I set the bulletin
board up in such a way that you couldn't
call in unless you came from one of
these very weird country codes that
corresponds with like Azerbaijan or
Kazakh Stan or Estonia or something and
in there and on your bulletin board you
would talk about hey I just hacked into
this oh no no no this book board we
didn't even talk we just shared code
this was called lucid nightmare
Wow all right this is insane
so look you look up on blinking cursor
like Yannick from wherever he's from
Sweden or something we go just send you
a program those guys were too friendly
and nice if you're mad Swedish people
they're like the nicest people they
really are cool yeah
no no play one of those guys none mean
Russian dudes I'm talking scary people
with thick accents well you couldn't
hear them you could just chat with them
that scares me more yeah that's curious
people so so how did you two get into it
did your dad get into it did he have a
nerd friend in high school did it cuz
this is all high school right oh is he
yeah it was it was quite it was quite
the opposite my dad did everything he
possibly could to stop it really oh he
knew yeah but we were solving equipment
like dad buy it for you he must have put
Thank You Man it wasn't that amazing I
had it I had an old Atari 800 that's how
I got started with the modem with the
acoustic coupler and then later I had in
a 286 PC and that was when things got a
little insane things got really scary
and you're the way you know your parents
are your kid is screwing up on you know
normally like you know these their eyes
are all red they're coming home
stoned you know they're there you can
tell in or they're breaking it to
russian-backed from the basement yeah
until 6:00 in the morning right like
hacking all night long bleary-eyed don't
go to school the next day and then like
he's doing something weird here yeah
something's wrong with Shaun he's not
here he's want to go to the zoo today uh
so then you you ended up just like with
all these different things you started
just hacking did you think that you were
gonna make money off it or was it just
for the interest of it the fun of it
hacking or starting companies hacking
hmm hacking yeah no I mean I was I was
considered a what I like a grey hat so I
would do bad people a different colored
hats
oh yeah different colored hats yeah you
can actually walk into a hacking store
they put the hats up on the left and you
pick one yeah and that's how you that's
how you get your identity yeah um go
like masks to accent Hanson no no this
ain't like bed of Mick here's there's a
white hat a white hat is a good hacker
who's not really even a
in that sense of the word there they are
a computer security professional then
there's a gray hat and a black hat and
they are sort of mischief makers and the
gray hats are the kind of mischief
makers who think they're really doing
good but they're not you know you learn
that when the FBI shows up your doorstep
the again we had different childhood
yeah yes the black hats they're the ones
who you want to watch out for there are
the malicious hackers who were there to
destroy
I just wanted to the fun of destroying
for the fun of destroying their really
real and I knew some of those guys and
they were sociopaths that was my first
introduction to sociopaths yeah you
actually dealt with in that conversation
with sociopaths it's a weird thing yeah
yeah of course it is yeah I mean I mean
I mean yeah it is not fun but you know
I've been to a few parties I mean you
gotta get is this you uh Union are we
are we're yeah we're on topic over here
I was going to ask you five and a
quarter disks or three and a half Oh God
you don't have to answer that I'm asking
the tough questions are you asking me
about about my penis size yeah that's
coming question number nine is that I'm
gonna close on that but uh should we get
you we just wrapped again it's five and
a quarter three and a half to it but it
will wait to that but I had a cuz I was
saying when I grew up I had these five
and a quarters and you would get these
video games and like the hero's quest or
King's Quest or Space Quest I don't
remember this should we get like 12
disks and that would you put them in
there and that was mhm and then three
and a quarter was like hard and was like
indestructible these are the new cool
little three and I could open it up and
a lot of kids in school couldn't even
open it up that was a that was my trick
so where's your guy in five and a
quarters the five and a half's worth
floppy the three and corners were hard
yes got it that's the opposite yeah
again I'm gonna skipper that last
question um what did
what you learn from from starting so
early and what have you learned from
your failures because I'm you know that
failures is kind of the only way you
really learn right hmm yeah I get I
usually I this is the correct way to ask
the question because I usually get asked
the question you know how did you
succeed and I and I really don't feel
like I've succeeded I feel like I've
sort of failed systematically at least
in terms of my own goals and you know
what I what I set out to do but then
somehow failure has kind of you know
transformed into some weird kind of
success that I wasn't that I wasn't
really expecting so what was the
question I'm sorry I'm just being know
that our saddest a know that oh you're
not know I thought what have you learned
from your failures I mean new because I
mean I don't know that what what I know
but I mean I know from being a comedian
that you know it you can tell jokes and
be funny for an hour but once you get
your first joke that doesn't work that's
where you learn how to craft a joke you
go hey why didn't that work how could I
make it work and why you know should I
try that joke again like why would I why
do they don't not laugh but they laughed
at everything else they hate me now yeah
exactly and then your confidence is shot
and it's like you know yeah you know you
hear that in any sports thing you read
about any boxer will say until you get
knocked down that's how you show your
character if can you get back up and can
you win the fight
so I mean talk about some of your knock
downs I mean did you have any projects
that flopped when you thought we're
gonna be huge you know it's always been
kind of a bittersweet and it's always
been a little bit ambiguous with me um
you know so I mean Napster wasn't day
wasn't a commercial success
Napster actually left everybody deeply
in debt and and left everyone actually
with personal liability in huge lawsuits
and it you know there was a period of
time where I was actually quite afraid
that if I ever made any money it would
be an incentive for the record labels to
to resume litigation against me
personally so I lived under this dark
cloud after Napster and the whole thing
ended so
kind of ignominiously for me because you
know I had these females that I've
written just a few emails here and there
and we all had emails and we all said
things we shouldn't have said but mine
were really bad
yeah is it yeah you can where we mine
for examples - yeah right when you're
when your words are blown up like you
know in huge texts like you know bigger
than us actually on a gigantic screen in
a Kuwaiti six point font yeah 275 yeah
crazy couriers it looks like a giant
typewriter exactly exactly
you make fonts I like wing-dings why I
think wing-dings is just so beautiful I
can tell you that was the best one yet
so useful then so Napster was a weird
was a very onion in it and and when
you've had that kind of cultural impact
so quickly because the whole thing for
those of you don't know the show was one
of the creators of Napster just so if
people were straining me on the web
they'd sure they know who you are but
just in case you don't know he was one
of the creators Sean and another Sean as
well that's great call yourselves Sean
and John like like like a band name yeah
yeah good boy BAM like like we should
have called Napster Sean and Sean Sean
Sean both had Bieber haircuts right
right right right like the brothers the
brothers Sean brother Sean yeah weird
I'm Chauncey Couture outfits Sean and
Sons
John and Sons is good yeah well think
about it we did we consider these
options son so Natura came out and that
did how did you get did you get money
from Napster no and well he left me
pretty much bankrupt and and and and and
with this huge shadow that I had to sort
of deal with this penumbral shadow of of
success and yet no one wants to be and
then wants to touch you anymore no once
again yes but you know what and they
will in the bubble had burst so Napster
had been sued out of existence the
company failed on you know at that stage
in my life I could have easily been like
a one-hit wonder and kind of you know
drifted off into obscurity and and and I
wanted I wanted to do something that was
a consumer product as my next company
but nobody would fund consumer there was
absolutely no interest consumer internet
was the redheaded stepchild of
the Internet at that point now it's all
the rage and that's all the VCS want to
fund his consumer Internet but backing
this is 2002 timeframe it changed with
the paypal IPO in 2002 but meanwhile I'd
been raising money for one and a half
years unsuccessfully sleeping on couches
like I had I hadn't set up a set of
rules for myself about how long I would
free load off of any one individual what
was the time you remember it was a you
know I two weeks but I would stretch
that to a week by mowing their lawn and
yeah yeah hey I made you guys mac and
cheese so can I say an extra vehicle
yeah that's with truffles with truffle
yeah right we are now butter for travels
back then but then you get in sir then
so you you you get into like angel
investing is that what happens I mean
how do you how does one has a kid from
Virginia huh do you have to live in San
Francisco do you have to live in New
York City is there a certain air you
have to we'll see it's a lot easier if
you live in the San Francisco Bay Area
because that's where I mean that's where
the that's where the bulk of the money
is consolidated I think you can start an
Internet company from from anywhere I
mean a great example this is one of the
companies on closely involved with now
called Spotify which is in Stockholm
it's a modified coming to the u.s. it is
coming yeah it's comics this is it this
is a huge it is coming it is it's a
giant in overseas and it's just
basically streaming music where you get
to just give your friends playlists it's
like that and it's all legally done oh
it's way better than that
oh yeah well please really indulge and
delve
it's really really really cool it's um
it's the realization of the dream that
Fannie and I had with Napster we had all
these product designs at Napster that we
never got to implement that we never got
Stu they never saw the light of day
because we were dealing with this
lawsuit and the lawsuit was actually
forced us to remove things from the
product so it was one of the only
products in the world that just from the
day it launched it was really cool and
then it went backwards so we held these
ideas about music sharing it was never
supposed to be just search and retrieval
and download it was supposed to be about
massive large-scale sharing of music b2b
reviews are your music fan crazy about
music yeah just like listening to it and
playing it no you don't you might you
know pretend
play it from time to time do what
instruments you play no I don't really
play the instrument I pretend to play
them like air guitar air guitar is
really good but it's not the crux of the
thing would Spotify is that you can see
all your users all of your friends on
Facebook and you can see their entire
music collections and then you can you
can even in coming versions see like
what they're listening to at this exact
moment and and you know it's that
element of live and seeing what your
friends are listening to seeing the last
hundred songs they've listened to that's
really really powerful and enables it
makes music viral
it's a little embarrassing too isn't it
sometimes it is from my playlist I mean
it yeah you see oh my gosh you're
listening to Wham Barbara's Friday yeah
I mean yeah I gotta go for Metallica to
Barbra Streisand sure you can hide a
playlist you don't have to you know show
them everything okay and I'm not ashamed
of my musical tastes Oh sometimes I I
have a lot of am gold Yacht rock stuff
it's pretty good I mean I'm I guess I'm
not really ashamed but I think it's fun
it's fun to see other people's then I
can get inspired by other people go like
oh where you think that's cool I would
laugh at them yeah huh yeah we're look
we're laugh at them right yeah exactly
laughing oh you oh my gosh you like that
cheesy song so do i I could sing
word-for-word the whole album yeah
that's kind of fun but I mean so how why
hasn't it come to the United States or
because of rights issues labels it's
it's an ongoing licensing conversation
what we're trying to do is I don't think
it's radical it to me it seems like
almost like sort of a sort of obvious
having used it and having thought about
it for a long time prior to prior to
these guys creating it and making it
work like my describe what would you do
on Spotify you log in you log in so this
is the cool part there's a there's a
sort of free tier of service that so
anybody can download the client without
putting in a credit card and instantly
they have access to all the world's
music at their fingertips everything you
can search for whatever you want
instantly it pops up double click on it
instantly start streaming there's no
download times how is that possible if
you're free amazing technology so then
the way the way the company monetizes is
that we get the user invested in music
we get them excited about music they
build playlists typical playlist has 22
songs on
typical user has you know over ten
playlists so they start to accumulate
this library of music so you can't use
iTunes to build a library of music until
you've bought the songs here you get to
build this vast library of music you get
you get the song stuck in your head it's
annoying you you want them you want them
on the road with you you want them on
your iPod you want to burn them to CD
you want to stream it to your iPhone
that's the point where we monetize so
once you've built your collection then
we start pushing you upgrade this
playlist you know but take it with you
you know but sync this playlist to your
to your iPod burn this playlist to see
anything and then we charge you so use
free streaming but if you want to buy it
for you if you want poor Zune if you
want portability mobility and access
then you buy zoom joke sorry uh those
don't usually work out no they don't but
uh there's some kid at home laughing
holding a Zune it's pretty funny ah so
you think Steve Jobs knew iCloud thing
this this is this is not what that is
this is you think it's no totally I'm an
iCloud is like a feature you know it's
it's it should be it's it's just not
that significant in the other way all
you really do is take your music and
upload it to this to this cloud and then
it's there I don't know why anybody
would do that that's a good that's a
good thing there uh and I'll charge you
for that's even weirder to me and they
charge you for just doing that yeah yeah
because you I can already do that yeah I
don't get it why have you seen a
turntable that FM that's cool that's
cool that's a cool new thing I just I
just got into that recently I like those
little bobble heads yeah I like it's
very it's a cool cool new thing and I
don't know that that owns if it's legal
I don't know how long it'll last but
it's out there now I think it might not
be legal okay it's not legal like I said
I've never used it and
just stay away for that awful thing
let's talk a little bit about Facebook
because you help make Facebook what it
is today is Facebook it
I don't think Facebook is the it I don't
think it's the end game I think they're
going to invent something like a VCR
where you don't even realize that you're
using it you know a VCR when it first
came out you're like I'm written movies
I'm taping movies I'm using it to turn
my analog TV set into a digital look I
can use a remote control and flip
channels that's when the first command
you go know you're using a VCR that's
all you're doing but you don't realize
that you just think like hey look I'm
just doing this um I'm getting all my
movies from this thing I'm taping all my
shows I'm changing my schedule of my
life because I'm taping shows so your
life is now changing because of the VCR
and you don't think about that you just
think that oh everyone's got one yeah
you know what that's actually that's a
pretty good description of where you
want to keep where you want to be with
any product you actually don't really
want people thinking your product is
cool you know you don't want people
using your product because it's cool
because then you're a fad what you want
is people using your product because
it's a part of their life and they can't
stop using it yeah yeah so I think
there's gonna be a box somewhere where
it's the remote control TV is your phone
was that how you hold the phone yeah
like a giant phone but it's also that
but also you can have a conversation
about the TV show you're watching and
also check your bills pay your bills and
just get everything done with one bleep
blorp yes right I went to do your point
is Facebook the endgame it's never the
end game Facebook has now become a
platform upon which all kinds of
applications are being built and it's
definitely not you know I would I would
be I would be incredibly presumptuous
and
and and and and self-serving of me to
believe that Facebook was the end of
history yeah I think it's kind of
evolved and I think is gonna inspire a
way it could possibly be the end of the
history the end of history is if you
know it somehow becomes in some sort of
artificial superintelligence that takes
over the world but short of that it's
not the end game that could happen to uh
what do you think myspace went wrong
where did myspace go wrong I failure to
execute the product development they
they wouldn't they weren't successful in
in iterating and evolving the product
quickly enough the product was basically
a this junk heap of bad design that that
persisted for many many years and and
they never there was a period of time
where they if they had just copied
Facebook rapidly yeah they would have
been they would have been Facebook but
they were giant mice they were the
network effects the scale effects were
enormous there was so much power there
do you think College helped like I feel
like Facebook is more of a personal like
thing where like a lot of people heard
about through their college going
we entered the market we entered the
market through college and the reason we
went in through college was because you
myspace users were generally college
kids were generally not myspace users
college kids were generally not
Friendster users it was this completely
open market and it was a real long shot
I mean nobody actually believed outside
of us you know three or four people in
Palo Alto that you could enter the
market through this niche market and
then gradually through you know this
kind of carefully calculated war against
all the other networks become the one
network to rule them all
I would you say Lord of the Rings rest
my friends yes it was it's actually I
have a poster of it over my bed uh along
with your Dungeons & Dragons post and an
official Harry Potter one good what I
was gonna say was uh I forget uh what
was gonna say oh yeah I was gonna ask
you bad would you consider yourself a
technology person it's good question I
started as a technology person so I had
I did have some kind of interest
technology but I've always been much
more interested in in building great
products than in building technology you
know the technology thing for me has
always been kind of like this this
somewhat tedious extremely difficult
execution phase of the business where
you actually to do stuff and it's hard
and you have to hire people and you're
like code and you know what I'm much
more interested in the implicate product
experiences whether it's in music or
social media or whatever did you ever do
you always care about money do you care
about money don't really care about
money
I've never how much I've never cared
about money either yeah to be honest but
can I borrow a million dollars
hey just cuz I don't care I don't really
care yeah I don't don't really care you
can talk about all right good yeah and
by Barah I mean just give it uh that's
what I really mean um like what do you
what do you do with it you want to start
a tech company yeah
III you know I am a VC now what does
that mean I haven't figured that out
okay
but a million is just starting title
exactly I definitely have ideas I would
love to dick sit down and talk about
ideas of course they're crazy but who
knows is good are we okay yeah oh I want
to remind everybody to tweet questions
and hash tag next to work n e xt wo RK
not you guys here are you right here
you'll need to tweet but uh people at
home who are watching can tweet some
questions but like Jeff do you have a
phone with apps do you use but can I see
your phone can I want you really want to
see my phone yeah I want to see what
apps you have in your phone I'd love to
see that so you asked me about a Maya
tech guy I'm not I'm not like one of
these one of these early adopters that's
sort of like you know it's annoying
because I'm on the board to my
entrepreneurs because I'm on the boards
of a bunch of companies that build
iPhone apps but I don't actually use an
iPhone I just crank through huge amounts
of email I'm kind of behind the times
actually let me let me see what apps you
have on your phone and then I'll tell
you actually if I can find it I mean do
you have like I mean a bird's eye but
hold on a second here I dropped it all
right here you go
this is
you're getting four bars in New York
City that's pretty awesome aging how the
hell did you do that how did you do that
this is a guy design that's unbelievable
yeah yes we have a few apps on here uh
yeah you have you already minutes for me
when it's your battery life is it this
is this is uh this is analog baby Oh
what is that right yeah you want you
want to keep this yeah probably good for
you know my gift from me so you don't
you don't do daddies or not you don't
have an iPhone to use use it blackberry
ah you know I do carry an iPhone but
mostly for music I'm not like I'm not
hip stow Matic really annoys me
Hipstamatic lipscomb attic yeah it's so
it's like it's like that why does
everything need to have that sepia toned
binder because people like that they
like putting on mustaches an old cowboy
hats and doing that you know and getting
some cotton candy and having fun I guess
right it's just fun that's why I think
that's fun like I like about apps is
that they're $0.99 number one if they're
free that's even do you work for Apple
yes I do
uh my name is Todd jobs I'm Steve's uh
Alicia
uh no I don't know I mean like but apps
I guess if people have apps on droid
phones yeah you know I think just think
it's it's almost I think weirdly I don't
know like that would you know anything
about like game consoles would you care
about game cuz I had a huge problem when
I was younger when I was 16 I had a huge
problem with gaming to the point where
was taking over my life and I had all of
these aspirations you know I wanted to
become a better super hacker and you
know break into more more you know
systems more regularly
I wanted to write rise in the ranks of
my you know II lead underground
community of cyber criminals like I
needed status from them and gaming was
holding me back what would be the name
of joy then when I realized I mean I'm
we were going way back here to like you
know 2002 you know yeah especially real
way back yeah like 96 12/5 like the
original like like Wolfenstein 3d oh
yeah first doom I mean that was like
crack for for me back then yeah so I
made the decision cold turkey
no games have not played a game I have
not played a game in at least fourteen
years really
no angry birds no angry birds no I won't
touch it
my fiancee was really into plants vs.
zombies so I had to suffer I had to
suffer through that for for a while a
few weeks of that while we're on them do
you think it's a waste of brain energy
or what do you feel like what what are
you gonna have foam do you neither relax
do you think that I haven't I have an
extremely addictive personality so I had
to find something to replace the gaming
which was you know boozing and whoring
no just kidding
I'm gonna cross that question up to it
um but I mean the dude what did
something had two feet do you drink to
relax and do you listen to music to
relax you have hard drugs hard drugs
only hard drugs hard drugs only yeah of
course that yeah but once you you can't
mainline it it's not worth doing but
once that's out of your system
seriously though what like your brain is
always moving it's always thinking uh -
don't you ever want to just zone out do
you think of meditation do you do any of
that stuff I know you're into tea what
you read that did I know everything
about manage did you learn to tea right
wait are you one never yeah I work for
the tea company so I'm from Savoie how
are you I actually have my own I'm the
lady from Snapple commercials I've got a
lot of work done I have my own I have
whatever we're doing right now they're
not liking it cuz it says move to QA no
they're fine they're liking it they're
like it I want to know I'm a do you what
do you do what do you do to relax what
do I do to relax well you sit down you
have tea what is the best tea that you
have where do you get it from I blend my
own tea actually and this is very
interesting cuz humans don't do this
right you get a Tetley bag and you put
in a cup of hot water and you sit back
and that's it you blend your own tea I
blend my own team does that mean you cut
your own bark and like grow your own
herbs and flowers tea is a leaf actually
well sometimes yeah also mushroom as
well
up to you oh you drink whatever to you
like to drink I mean if you really want
to know I take Indian Assam which is a
cut ground up into these little pellets
looks like gerbil food or bird food or
something then I take I take a key mum
tea from China which is a very multi
kind of you know classic English
breakfast ingredient and I blend those
together and then I throw in the secret
sauce and you can't say what that is
I'll show you later if you come by my
planes all right I'll do it I'll do it
yes I'll give you a sip I appreciate it
thank you so much let's take a little
some questions if anyone has any
questions for me or Shawn yes sir we
have microphone coming to you in case
you want to break into song up to you a
one two three four a question back in
the early part of mm at decade when you
and Shawn were going through the
lawsuits with the record industry
whatever did you ever get a phone call
from Steve Jobs because it seems to me
that the success of Apple was largely
due in part to the success yes I agree
and I like the way you think and I think
what you might be saying is that I I'm
owed at least a few cents per iPods sold
and so if you want to take that up with
Steve on my behalf I would be happy and
I'll give you a cut yeah well let's just
say for this interview and me this would
never have happened so cut me in as well
let's not it's not around the
issue yes sir over here I have a
question my name is Tim Lewis
two panels ago or something I want to
have a question about Facebook which you
were talking about how Facebook came to
a market dominated by an existing scaled
up company what is your intuition as as
a VC as to when a company is going to be
able to take on another company already
has massive amounts of scale did you
have some intuition that myspace was
weak or did I just want to have any
thoughts about that well you didn't need
intuition I know that myspace was weak
you know was a totally dominated by
these
kind of never heard of the myspace
angles anyway
that's where you you know take pictures
of yourself from funny angles to try to
make yourself look cool and the whole
thing was like fraudulent in the sense
that all of these users were were not
representing themselves honestly they
were representing they were you know to
put it nicely they were putting their
best foot forward and some of them were
existing in a complete fantasy world of
their own construction so there was this
where you pay any attention to them at
the time or just doing your own thing I
was you know trolling for women on
MySpace all day long you know trying to
get laid
well that's what everybody was doing by
the way I'm sorry I never got back to
you uh turns out I'm not a 18 year old
girl I buzz yes yes yeah uh but you just
kind of I just assumed that you were
like a federal agent yeah I'm still not
gonna admit to that this talk is not
helping my reputation
oh you can't help that reputation buddy
let me tell you something right now uh
but sou that's a good question no did
you it's not like you went saw something
had a hole it was weak and you go like
let's destroy that combo I was
interested in this problem of identity
I'm gonna make the talk boring again no
um I really cared about trying to try it
there was no identity layer for the
Internet there was no verifiable
accountable persistent identity that
could follow you from place to place
that would that was that you you you
maintained and curated in an accurate
way and MySpace wasn't doing that and
until you get to until you establish
that identity layer for the internet a
lot of things aren't really possible you
don't have trust you don't have
accountability certain transactions
can't take place between people like you
know selling someone your fish on
farmville that couldn't happen
you needed identity to enable all of
this all of these all of these
applications and MySpace wasn't
providing that so the vision in some
sense Facebook and MySpace were very
similar but the vision driving both of
those companies was coming from a
totally different place myspace is
almost more virtual reality than a real
reality which is real like I remember
playing The Sims game yeah it's a great
game but you've missed out on and
does it get the part of the game where
you can make your character work out on
the treadmill and I remember watching I
was making my character workout and I
was eating a pizza I should be working
out this is insane I was really proud of
myself my god that's this guy's gonna
work his butt off this is fantastic it's
to another five minutes this guy owner
of work is like oh wait what am i doing
and I was just getting fat playing Sims
but it was fun but uh but I know you're
saying is like now Facebook has actually
become a people's lives I mean that's
how they give photos to each other
videos and just everything recipes etc
etc any other questions I want to get to
some more questions you sir right there
i bribe Hersman
nice to meet you um we're nice to be
here in the conference and like I hope
going back to the money question this is
more of a philosophical thing because
you know I know a lot of people who have
become very successful because of their
heart and their goals and it's more of
an emotional thing than a drive to you
know make a lot of money so the question
I have is does that switch or that
philosophy reverse itself as you make
more and more money
mm-hmm and why isn't that mmm so I think
that there's two types of people there's
always two types there's two types of
people in terms of the way they react to
to wealth and I think some of it has to
do with your initial motivations are you
motivated you know by simply making
money becoming wealthy status prestige
or is there some you are you trying to
change the world in some specific way to
solve a specific problem that sort of
arcs you or you know maybe it doesn't
bother you but you see the problem in
the world and you you realize that it it
ought to be fixed and so depending on
where you start out I think it affects
kind of where you end up and so I've
seen I've seen I've seen folks who make
a billion dollars and they say that's it
I'm done I'm getting off this
merry-go-round you know see you guys
later and
and I'm going to the beach or I'm going
to help try to Africa to save the world
and then there's the there's the people
who see it as a scorecard and they get
trapped in this like endless cycle of
self rec-room recrimination hudson
challenging words right scrabble word
yeah so they get trapped in this endless
endless cycle where they don't feel like
they're succeeding fast enough and now
suddenly they're comparing themselves
only to other billionaires and they're
trying to they're worried about their
position in the forbes list and they'll
never say it publicly but you know you
know that's privately it's actually it's
it's it's totally totally explicit like
they're the conversations are about net
worth and the conversations are about
you know whose dick is bigger than then
it is so I think you can there's just
different ways that people react to it
and I mean personally I don't I don't
really full see faults in either way I
don't think it's anything inherently
wrong with seeing wealth as a scorecard
and trying to work your way up that
scorecard as long as you're not hurting
people on the way up is yeah but also
like the bigger your business gets the
more people are involved right because I
mean when did you just start out in your
house it's you and your buddy and you're
making a lot of money that's cool but
now if you have this giant business it's
thousands of people employed yeah a
little bit more pressure you don't want
to screw up totally yeah yeah I mean
that's you don't even want to screw up
just on the perspective of you know you
have a lot of people who you're
responsible for in their and their lives
and their families are built around the
success of your company that's a ton of
responsibility yeah you know it's tricky
balance yes over there there's a
gentleman right there you're getting two
microphones so you can ask a question in
stereo if you would like to my name is
hameed abbas and here for magazines is a
software digital publishing software now
my question is this you had a lot of
success with you know with with with a
music industry now you're taking a music
streaming it especially with your latest
product and you work with them and they
allow you to stream this music for free
now think of this from the publishing
industry what can we do or how
we overcome this problem that we allow
to share bits and pieces of content
publishing content like articles you
know from various publishers into one
platform and sharing it how can we
overcome this how can we move forward
with publishers to understand us that
they should be able to the same thing no
one would want to pay for the entire
magazine so instead they would you know
they would take pins and bases of cotton
which is valuable to people take it and
share it how can we do it from our end
to overcome the same problem that you
have already done you know I actually
think that each and that different
medium should be monetized in different
ways I don't believe there's a
one-size-fits-all approach to monetizing
media I think and the reason for that is
that the consumption patterns are
completely different so with film with
film you you don't have a very good
experience of film if you own and you
can have it perfectly perfectly adequate
experience of film if you own one one
DVD or two DVDs or three you watch it
once or twice and you're sort of done
with it with music you're listening to
the same songs over and over you're
building playlists you get sick of one
playlist or one song you make another
one you get sick of an artist you move
on
you're constantly exploring then you're
going back and revisiting your old
favorites and they sound different and a
different context or they're nostalgic
it's a whole different consumption
pattern and if you don't have a few
thousand songs in your collection today
you're probably not getting the full
experience of music so there's you know
that's a really distinct difference the
publishing business is not one that I've
you know I'm particularly you know close
to I haven't I haven't build companies
in that world I'm not sure exactly what
the balance is I think that there's
definitely a room room for pay walls and
and and
and premium content and there's
definitely room for ad-supported you
know and supported free content and I
think it depends on the publication I
think actually the publishing industry
while it's going through a difficult
time I think they kind of understand
what the models are unlike with the
music industry where for years there's
been this baffling question about what
should the model be I think actually the
question about how you distribute mute
and sell music is a more difficult
question than the question about how do
you make money you know with words and
you know selling words on the screen and
and and so forth
thanks for really bringing the interview
down sir it looks like you sorry any
more questions that are in party-pooper
right we have one here this one's from
Twitter can Shawn talk about Facebook's
new design oriented acquisitions design
oriented acquisitions like the Cup
Facebook buying companies that have have
great design teams and things like that
I guess I guess well I don't know I
didn't write that tweet
twitter twitter tell us tell us what you
mean oriented acquisitions I guess
farmville I guess no no no I think I
don't know what they're talking about
but anyway I think design is really
important I'm a designer and like open
faced with new look new layout what are
they talking about for though I think
they're talking about I think they're
talking about buying companies for their
design talent in order to I mean these
are these these are like hardcore
Facebook this is inside baseball right
here I see we're saying so to take
Facebook to the next level like people
have different design ideas they go you
should change a design by doing this
we're good at this right and so we hire
people who are like now that doesn't
really make sense right yeah exactly and
they're like it should really be like
this so can you talk about new design
oriented acquisitions I actually don't
know what they are because I don't track
it that closely but I but I have in the
past had conversations with with mark
where I've said you know you guys should
really be buying more buying more
companies in acquiring more talent and I
think you know designers are a key part
of that equation so I can all I can say
about it is if they've if they've been
making good design oriented acquisitions
then then good for them and
that's the right strategy is mark a
weird question uh what's this go-to
karaoke song oh it has to be journey
don't stop believe it of course awesome
any other questions yes ma'am over there
hi Liz Porter um based on your
background as a non hacker and your
interest in the experience and
understanding experiences have you
thought about or have you been asked to
look at from the cybersecurity aspects
of the network
well question I think it's for me
the questions for me uh go for it I have
been asked a few times and I've said no
very loudly in capital letters enter sin
he can't divulge his secrets yeah I
appreciate that
uh that would you what could uh what's
she saying would uh I've never been
asked if you want it funnily enough I
did I don't know why I thought this was
a good idea at the time but when I was
16 years old after I've been raided by
the FBI I needed work so I decided to
start a computer security firm it made
perfect sense to me at the time and I
had clients which is even scarier they
were hiring a 16 year old can you know
convicted felon - I wasn't actually
convicted because when you're a kid they
put you through this whole other thing
which leads to anyway they slap on the
wrist and they take your computer away
and they call it a day but I I did I
started a computer security firm and I
and I and I we actually was with Shawn
Fanning and we had like a couple clients
so basically if you sign with your firm
you will never get hacked uh yes exactly
like I'm actually gonna protect you
about what are you we're actually we're
not gonna protect you we're just gonna
tell our protection racket not to screw
with you yeah that's it but you know
that weirdly not Evel Knievel did that
so what kind of how he got his name and
the mob yeah and the mob as well yeah
but I go right back to Evel Knievel uh
but he had a thing where it's like it
was local town he's like we'll be
security for your house and whoever
whatever business didn't sign with Evel
Knievel they threw a brick through who's
bent and broken this art Witte store and
trashed the place it's called a
protection racket it's it's a common
mafia a product yeah so you tried that
and then you wouldn't try it again
what you wouldn't you wouldn't try
everything again would you no okay
uh sorry hold on a second yep it's
screech from Saved by the Bell
he uh he has to call you oh I know I can
tell him he heard you okay uh we're out
of time I just want to thank you guys
for listening to us I want to thank Sean
Parker for being candid and funny and
interesting and we're excited to see
what's gonna happen with Spotify I'm
this is cue very cool they got to talk
to you and thank you all for listening
[Applause]